mich hat heute auch etwas schockiert
oder eher verwundert und zwar habe ich
den schritt meiner kollegin judith barth
gesehen und sie hat das geteilt was sie
gerade sehen und zwar jackie o pur
village es ist von dem funk account
mädelsabend eben über 200 tausend
follower und da sieht man ganz genau
hautfarbe weiß später kommt noch frau
mann schlank mehrgewicht ich
heterosexuell oder homosexuell und
deines chikyu privilege ich finde dass
völligen irrsinn warum der mensch in
schubladen 1 teilen wollen ich habe von
klein auf gelernt egal wie jemand ist
egal ob jemand eine andere hautfarbe
andere sexualität hat oder einen anderen
glauben hat ist er genau gleich warum
also gibt es jetzt trafen wo genau ein
kategorisiert wird wie man ist und wo
man eigentlich auf der privilegiert
haitianer ist hier sehen wir es jetzt
noch mal ich finde es mehr als schwierig
und medien ist von funk funk gehört zu
den öffentlich rechtlichen medien
der account wird also dementsprechend
auch mit steuergeldern finanziert hier
möchte ich mal sagen dass auch tolle
stories angebote von mädelsabend gibt
über tod über brustkrebs als ist ein
wichtiger account aber ich finde mit dem
jackie o pop litt starb laden sie
ziemlich wie soll man sagen daneben
gegriffen denn damit bin ich ja
eigentlich unter meinem kollegen philipp
er als ob er ein mann ist fühle ich mich
aber nicht ich fühle mich immer als
gleichberechtigt zu der fälle kerner das
ist jetzt wirklich kompliziert weil als
man will ich bin ich zwar laut funk
privilegierte als du allerdings bist du
christlich ich bin nicht christlich geld
zu einer religiösen minderheit also es
ist ganz unklar wo man in dieser
privilegierten hierarchie steckt und
ehrlich gesagt nur darum geht es geht um
diese neuen gesellschaftlichen
hierarchie die mannschaft überhaupt das
ist faszinierend dass diese bewegung die
sich für so progressiv hält und bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen noch immer
stärker wird das die wieder anfängt
menschen in gruppen in schubladen zu
stecken und dann sich natürlich nur
bestimmte aussucht es gibt ja noch ganz
vieles was menschen privilegiert das
einkommen der eltern die intelligenz
auch beispielsweise und auch ganz
alltägliche fragen die man sich gar
nicht so leicht definieren lassen wurde
mir zu hause vorgelesen oder nicht wurde
da worüber wurde da am tisch beim
abendessen gesprochen also ich halte
diese kategorien für vollkommen einen
stoß und aber das ja auch noch die frage
wozu eigentlich also wenn ich jetzt
herausgefunden habe dass ich
privilegiert bin was ich immer wenn ich
glaube das könnte herauskommen was mache
ich denn damit weiter dass jemand haben
das verstanden genau was ist das
übrigens und und was würde ich denke ich
angefangen ja was soll ich damit an weiß
dass jemand nach ich weiß also man
sensibilisiert sein also diese tafel uns
alle sensibilisieren darf also du sollst
nach dem anblick sensibilisiert sein
dass ich als frau weniger privilegien
habe als tun sollst dann mal schauen
will dem umfeld probieren mir zu heilig
sondern ganz
großer demütiger seien etwas weniger
reden auch hier schon leicht den
unterprivilegierten gruppen hierzu
gehören das tor anstatt einfach etwas
mehr redezeit für
sich braucht jetzt noch der weit
überwiegende teil der menschen
beurteilen andere nicht nach dieser
privilegierung skala sondern nach
verhalten nach charakter nach auftreten
ihnen gegenüber und wir diese tafel ließ
soll der jetzt selbstbewusstsein
entwickeln oder soll er sich schuldig
fühlen ich glaube dass die menschen viel
vernünftiger sind als wir ihnen gerne
unterstellen dass sie andere die nach
dieser methode unterprivilegiert sind
auch als solche behandelt werden an die
allermeisten behandeln ihr gegenüber in
augenhöhe und gucken nicht auf gewicht
oder hautfarbe wahrscheinlich sollen
diejenigen wieder als
unterprivilegierter unterstellt werden
selbstbewusstsein entwickeln und die
anderen wie philip gesagt haben die als
privilegiert besteht werden sich
zurückhaltend ich frage mich nur nach
den standards die wir heutzutage
eigentlich alle haben und oder anwenden
müssen ist das ja die total
diskriminierung ja denn wenn ich schon
hier jemanden als unterprivilegiert
darstelle der zu einer minderheit seht
dann diskriminiere ich die nacht den
burg kriterien natürlich völlig ich
kenne auch viele wollten wie die
selbstbewusst sind nach aus wie wie kein
anderer oder keine andere oder auch ist
nicht die idee diese ganzen black lips
matter bewegungen dass es ihr
selbstbewusstsein gibt auch für
diejenigen die eine andere hautfarbe ob
die so kategorisiert werden möchten ja
schlank und mehr gewicht ich das fand
ich auch ganz spannend also im moment
kämpft ja eigentlich social media dafür
dass es zum beispiel auch mehr kirby
models gibt als sollen ja alle formen
jetzt ausgelebt werden was richtig ist
was gut ist aber jetzt steht dort wieder
in einen kasten schlank in dem anderen
mehr gewichtige und ich glaube dieses in
schubladen einteilen alleine menschen zu
kategorisieren du bist übergewichtig um
dich und freiwillige also es ist ja aber
was ich weiß ich noch eine überhöhung
dazu finden und das fällt mir ganz oft
habe ich volk einigen funk accounts was
ich wirklich schwierig finde ist die
ideologisierung also funk der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk welcher jugendliche
damit informieren prinzipiell finde ich
die idee toll wie ich eben betont hat
mädelsabend auch wirklich tolle story is
da habe ich auch schon mal geschrieben
wie großartig die arbeit findet aber es
ist mir zu viel ideologie bei den
kanälen von funk es wird immer getan hat
super oft wird geändert das will
übrigens 70 prozent der bevölkerung und
nicht
dagegen aber andere und diese
ideologisierung jetzt auch wieder mit
dem check hier will ich aber diese
ganzen zum kanäle sind für mich sehr
ideologisch aufgeladen und ich frage
mich ob das sinnvoll ist auch für junge
menschen wenn sie diese tafel sehen wie
kommen wir in eine ganz komische lage du
sagst 70 prozent und das stimmt ja
wollen das nicht oder sind noch einmal
bereit fragen nach mehr sicherheit
bereit sich damit so zu beschäftigen wie
es viele gerne als notwendig erachten
aber diejenigen die sich dagegen
aussprechen werden mit einer solchen
vehemenz kritisiert das ist gar nicht
mehr tun ich hatte letztens ohne
diskussion am letzten samstag bei uns so
aus weil jemand zwei töchter nicht wie
herr bosbach aber nicht reich
sondern zwei aber er sagt ich habe ein
riesenproblem zu hause weil ich einmal
das wort hüben kurz gesagt habe und die
16 jährige tochter hat gesagt das geht
überhaupt nicht so
diesen begriff den man ganz genau die
süßigkeit aber der sagt ich verstehe die
welt nicht mehr weil ich kann mich gar
nicht mehr weil das nur ein beispiel für
viele wie er kann nicht mehr traut sich
in irgendeiner weise zu artikulieren
weil er nur ständig links und rechts
oder in sozialen netzwerken 1 um die
ohren kriegt es sind aber 70 prozent die
so empfinden das heißt bekommen hier
wirklich zu einer
spaltung der gesellschaft wo diejenigen
die solche begriffe verwenden oder sich
nicht nach dem burg mussten verhalten
ideologisch wirklich bekämpft werden er
war noch mal zurück zu meiner frage die
noch nicht beantwortet wurde also das
ganze dient dazu dass ich feststelle und
rosbach sie auch untereinander sie sie
nicht so haben sie ja selbst gesagt dass
wir drei stellen jetzt fest wir sehen
wir haben und wir da muss ja was daraus
folgen also wir sollen uns schlecht
fühlen ja das ist das ergebnis also ich
verantworten wir sollen uns zusammen
sagte er begleitet werden das ist
sensibilisiert sagen sie im kopf dann
ist das geht schon noch wie genau gegen
diese regierung über den auftrag
informationen und bewertungen hinweg
oder sie oder sie dass wir über
privilegiert sind wobei das vielleicht
gar nicht stimmt aber nach den
kategorien die dateien was soll sowas
oder warum es so was überhaupt erlaubt
wieso darf ich menschen gerade vom
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk also
einordnen sollte soll ja darum geht gar
nicht es soll darum gehen diese ganzen
angeblich unterprivilegierten gruppen
dann stärker zu fördern beispielsweise
durch quoten das interessante ist was
dabei nicht berücksichtigt wird auch
diese angeblich unterprivilegierten
gruppen können ja auch selbst durchaus
diskriminieren nehmen wir mal das
beispiel die muslimische gemeinde wie
hält die es eigentlich mit juden und mit
homosexuellen und mit frauen ob allah
gibt es da eventuell auch etwas
geht es gibt ein paar kassen für beide
glaubensgemeinschaft gemeinsam als
jüdisch schräg muslime
da gilt ja respekt vor anderen
religiösen kulturellen überzeugungen dar
da biegt man falsch ab wenn man da
gleiche maßstäbe also was ganz anderes
kann ja nicht so groß wie
es kann nicht bedeuten im übrigen also
meine von der wirklichen frauenbewegung
her kommt dass man dass das respekt
bedeutet dass ich hier
frauen hilfestellungen gebe also in
diesem sektor auf alte oder sonst
irgendwas weil ich damit frauen
kategorisieren als schwaches geschlecht
das ist schon ein absolutes no go also
die die 1
gepflogenheiten des alltags sie sind
auch nicht mehr genehm wenn es darum
geht das miteinander neu zu leben siehe
steffen freund kommentar länderspiel da
man bitte weggucken hat das auf eine
frechheit wie kannte das sagen ein
glückliches volk wo man sich also sowas
aufregt wo sie ein glückliches land sein
wenn die keine anderen sorgen war aber
wir regen uns heran da hat es ja schon
gesagt das ist ja eine kleine gruppe die
sich aufregt
[Musik]